Hello everybody. Hope that you are good.
This video is going to be my projection
for Bitcoin in 2026. So you want to see
if I'm bullish or if I'm bearish. Some
people will agree, some will disagree,
and that is totally fine. I would even
say that that's the whole point of this
video is that we learn from each other.
So if you have any different argument,
please leave it on the comment section
of this video. I'll try to answer as
many messages as I can. Um, I think
that's the whole point, you know, that
if I'm missing something, you can tell
me and if you are missing something,
maybe I can tell you, you know. So, this
video is going to be quite technical
because we're going to analyze a lot of
different things. So, I'm going to try
to keep the language quite simple and
also the video quite short so I don't
take much of your time. Now the first
thing that I want to talk about is the
N2 global liquidity index is this
indicator we have here and this shows
pretty much all the monetary supply of
the world includes the US and China
which are the two main countries
injecting liquidity out there and with
this chart all I want to show you this
yellow line is that Bitcoin tends to
follow it. Why? Well, simply because if
there is more money out there and more
liquidity into the system, then that
means that more people and more
institutions can buy Bitcoin. Okay,
everything grows also because inflation.
So, as you can see, it's always acts a
bit delay. For example, this top here is
here. This drop would be here, this
bottom. Okay, as you can follow. Now,
this pump for example that we see here,
in my opinion, that probably is around
this level. Okay.
Then you have this drop there. You got
it. Okay. Price goes up and I would say
that this is here. You see a drop that
will be there. Then you see price going
up. That would be this pump here. But if
you can see the yellow line is a bit
overextended. So I would say that we've
only got maybe to here. Okay. Then you
see this drop which is this drop in
Bitcoin. Two things to mention from
here. The first thing is that the
retrace in the yellow line is quite
small compared to the very deep retrace
that we are seeing in Bitcoin and I
would say that's because of three
things. The first thing is that Bitcoin
is very sensitive to the liquidity and
we had the US government shut down and
that's when Bitcoin started to act very
weak. The second thing that happened was
the 10th of October. That was a mess.
That was a record on liquidations. It
created a very long week. 8 9% within a
few minutes. I think in total price
dropped around 15% that day and some
market makers were caught on that
volatility. They lost money and in order
to rebalance their portfolios they were
forced to sell from 110K 115K they've
been selling until now. Okay. So that is
one thing. Now the question is you know
if they've been selling all of that time
how much is left to sell if there is
any. And the third thing that happened
is that over the last month we had this
very tight range and also very boring
price action and it was because we had
options at record levels and that forced
dealers to hedge their to hedge
automatically. So if price went up they
were forced to sell if price went down
they were forced to buy. So at the end
what you have here is a very tight range
and they're not giving any space for
breakouts or breakdowns. Okay. So now I
want to start to see price moving freely
because all those options expired on
Friday. Yesterday was the first day that
price was moving naturally without that
lead, you know. So that's pretty much
what I think that this retrace here has
been so big in Bitcoin. And the point
that I wanted to get to is that we still
have here in the M2 monetary supply, we
have an increase that Bitcoin hasn't
priced in yet. Okay, it's delayed. So
that would take Bitcoin above 130K to
all alltime highs. And usually Bitcoin
is delayed say four months, five months
maybe from the M2 global liquidity
index. So that is giving me maybe a hint
or an argument to why Bitcoin could
still going up because the global
monetary supply keeps increasing.
Central banks keep printing money and
that's my next argument. So let me
remove all of these. The next thing is
that the Fed, the US central bank, they
ended QT in December and also in
December they announced that they are
buying every month $40 billion of
treasury bills. Now the Fed is not going
to say that this is QE quantitative
easing and the reason is because what
they're going to say is because QE is
more about buying government bonds which
is more for the long term whereas
treasury bills is more like a short-term
kind of action. All right. So um but in
terms of the concept it is what it is.
they're injecting liquidity into the
system and when they're injecting
liquidity into the system that always
helps the stock market and risk assets
like Bitcoin to perform well. So that's
another reason why you know if there is
more liquidity to the system then stocks
and risk assets should go up more things
interest rates why is happening in the
US well Jerome Pow is finishing mandate
I think it's in May and Donald Trump is
going to pick somebody with the finger
to take that position Donald Trump said
many times that he wants 1% interest
rates now I don't know if they're going
to let him or if they're going to be
able to take interest rates to 1%
Their intentions are clear. Okay, they
want to continue cutting interest rates
which also is going to help the S&P and
crypto to perform well. All right,
that's all I'm going to say because I
don't know what it's going to happen at
the end, but we know their intentions.
Next thing is S&P 500 is at alltime
highs. Let's go to the S&P 500.
S&P 500.
Let me remove all of these alltime
highs. Okay. And if with what we've said
it continues to go up, then what is
going to happen with Bitcoin? It's
possible that for some reason we see a
retrace. Okay, you're going to have here
a strong support because you have this
area here that is a key level in the
chart and also you want to have the
weekly 50 MA coming through. this area
should probably hold and price continue
going higher. Okay, that's what I'm
thinking it probably happen in 2026
because all that we've said and also we
have the top companies of the S&P
expecting earnings in 2026 to be good.
Okay, so that is telling you in what
kind of situation we are in the market.
And now if we go back to Bitcoin,
let's go to a different chart because
this one is
I have some drawings. But you to this
chart, there are two things that we
could argue why the maybe the markets
could be going down in 2026. The first
thing is the weekly 50 MA. You can see
how the weekly 50 MA in my opinion is um
clearly one of the best bull and bare
market indicators.
Okay, this chart, by the way, is quite
short. So, let's go to this one. That is
much better. You can see how when price
is in a bull market is above the weekly
50. When it goes into a bare market is
below it. Of course, you see some
deviations like the COVID crash. Then
you have here bull market price above
the weekly 50 MA it holds. It makes a
new high. Then it drops tested a
resistance drops bare market gets it
back above it. Retest a support bull
market and now price is again below it.
Okay. So you could argue price is below
the weekly 50 main. This is a bare
market. Okay. Yes, it's possible for
that. We still need to see some kind of
retest as resistance and then price
could continue going lower. But I want
you to I want you to see guys that
sometimes we see some deviations. Okay,
below the weekly 50 May. What about
here? What happened there? Nothing
happened here. August and September of
2023.
not major news that caused a deviation
like the COVID crash did that was just a
natural deviation and then if you notice
price went back above it and continued
with a bull market. Why couldn't be the
same case here? Why couldn't this be a
deviation? I'm not going to say that
this is a deviation because first it
needs to be proved first needs to go
back above the weekly 50 MA and then
I'll say yeah that was a deviation here.
I can only say careful because it could
be a deviation.
Okay. And if this start of the bare
market, then give me a retest of the
weekly 50 May and let's see how how
price behaves from there. Also, too many
arguments in the macro context to
support that Bitcoin should continue
really to go up over the next year. What
about the fouryear cycle? You might say,
well, I've told you before that, and
you've noticed because I never talk
about it. I don't really care about the
fouryear cycle theory. I don't also care
about the monthly returns.
Things keep changing in crypto. I mean,
this year, for example, you are going to
have the first ever posthaling year in
negative. And that was a very strong
part of the theory of the four-year
cycle. is that the postalin year always
offers greater returns while this year
we are going to close in negative in
five or six% negative all right so you
can see that you know the crypto market
keeps changing every time there is more
liquidity every time we have you know
institutions coming in ETFs coming in
new exchanges market makers collapsed it
keeps changing so to me monthly returns
and
fouryear cycle it's things that I don't
really pay attention to okay because the
market is in constant change what I look
at is the price action because price
action doesn't change because human
behavior doesn't change okay now what
you can see here guys is something quite
interesting first I'm going to take you
to a couple of charts that are Nvidia
let's go to check Nvidia what happened
with Nvidia and I want you to pay
attention to what happened here
You have
this low over here in a uptrend. Price
was dropping and I can tell you that
there was a lot of panic here. Many
people were selling. Many people were
saying, "Well, okay, AI was a bubble.
It's going to continue going lower." And
what it did was a sweep of these lows.
Price went back above this level and
continue going up with the bull market.
You can see that now, you know, it's
continue with the bull market. But if
you notice this is a this is a chart
that you're going to see more often. If
you go with Google, you're going to see
pretty much the same. So
let me draw this part here.
Okay,
you have this level which should be a
strong support. You have the low. Price
sweeps the low, gets back above it,
retested, continues with the bull
market. All right. And if you go back to
Bitcoin, what do you guys see here?
Bitcoin in Coinbase. What do you guys
see here? I'm going to mark it for you.
Okay, you have
this strong support over here. You can
see it there.
Okay, you have that strong support over
there. What if price comes down here,
sweep these lows, retested and continues
with the bull market same as Nvidia and
Google did. I think it's quite similar
chart. Also, we have here a very strong
support that shouldn't break through is
if we are indeed in a bare market. All
right, but
that would be around a 40% correction in
Bitcoin. Let me check it with you.
Sorry, I'm doing something wrong there.
That's a 40% correction.
Right now, we are on,
let me check, 34%.
My opinion is that if price goes all the
way down here, then I think that this
price action is very likely to happen.
Also, I'm going to add you another
indicator is the Bitcoin mining cost.
This is how much it cost on average to
mine one bitcoin. You can see how right
now it's also matching exactly at a
level it's a $74,000
and in previous times if we zoom out you
can see that it doesn't really go below
it. Okay, the Bitcoin mining cost is
always
below the current price except when you
see some deviations like for example the
COVID crash then recovers fast. Okay.
Also here you see a really really small
deviation that was the bare market
bottom. Price continues going up from
there. Okay. Well, it starts to go up
from there. And now if you noticed
it's pretty much there. It's almost
there. you mean? So from here, I think
the bottom is very close. And what I'm
going to explain now, and I've explained
it in other videos, is that my analysis
for Bitcoin in the midterm is that I do
think that it's either going to sweep
these lows of 80K.
Okay, that is the chart.
Or if it loses this level 80K and it
starts to consolidate below it then
price is going to start to go lower and
it should stop around 74 73K where we
have you know these lows price can sweep
those lows
hit the mining cost price of bitcoin
that should also act as support or
that's what has happened previously many
times and that is pretty much what
Nvidia and Google has also printed okay
so If it's not the sweep of the lows of
79K, then it'll be the sweep of the lows
of this previous low at 74.5K.
Either way, the bottom is quite close if
it's not already in. That's what I'm
thinking. Okay, so yes, I'm bullish for
2026. All right, that is my opinion,
guys. Thank you for watching the video
and please comment your arguments for
agreeing on this bullish case. Maybe you
have different arguments or of course
disagreeing and you think that the bare
market is going to start. I'll be happy
to to read all the comments. So, thank
you so much for watching, guys, and I'll
see you